[Musique]
il existe un vieux proverbe persan quand
il touche la ferai le feu dévore aussi
bien le bois vert que le bois sec
cela pourrait être une bonne description
de la pandémie de kobe 19 qui a affecté
tous les pays de la planète
mais l'iran et les états unis plus que
d'autres ce nouvel ennemi invisible qui
a changé tant de choses dans notre vie
petite île bouleversée l'hostilité entre
les deux pays pour un discuter nous
retrouvons les ministre iranien des
affaires étrangères
java tarifs monsieur le ministre c'est
un réel plaisir de vous voir un moscow
et surtout en personne ravi de vous
rencontrer à nouveau
vous êtes l'un des premiers d'un petit
nombre de dignitaires à avoir pris le
vol pour moscou ces derniers jours je
voudrais vous demander comment cette
pandémie at-elle modifié le travail des
diplomates
avez-vous des conversations sur zoom
comme la plupart d'entre nous ou ce
n'est pas à considérer comme
suffisamment sécurisés comme moyen de
communication à la clé en fait nous
sommes obligés d'utiliser cela
ce matin j'ai d'ailleurs participé à une
réunion dans le cadre de la conférence
sur l'interaction la coopération et le
renforcement de la confiance en asie
une vidéoconférence plus de 20 ministres
des affaires étrangères y ont participé
et comme vous le disiez dans votre
introduction le virus ne fait aucune
distinction entre les riches et les
pauvres les forts et les faibles les
amis et les ennemis
il affecte tout le monde avait il montre
aussi que nous devons nous unir pour
combattre ce virus
malheureusement les états unis
continuaient à empêcher l'iran d'acheter
même des médicaments et des vaccins
contre ce virus
nous allons sans doute en parler en
détail mais laissez moi vous poser une
question de plus sur le travail des
diplomates car d'après ce que vous avez
dit j'ai compris que cela se réduisait à
des déclarations publiques
ce n'est pas un problème de faire ça en
ligne mais vous êtes tout de même venu à
moscou
serait ce à cause du caractère très
sensible de certains sujets qui rend la
discussion à distance en possible en
fait c'est ma troisième visite à moscou
depuis le début
l'épidémie de covin il ya des choses
dont il faut discuter personnellement
muse bien sûr nous procédons tous par
visioconférence que ce soit zoom ou
n'importe quelle autre plateforme
disponible mais il ya toujours des
choses qui doivent être abordés en
personne dans des conditions normales un
diplomate de votre statut bénéficierait
d'une immunité totale
vous ne pouvez pas être fouillée on ne
peut pas vous imposer de test le coc u19
at il changé quelque chose je veux dire
avez vous besoin de demander à vos
homologues de fournir des preuves qu'il
ne présente pas de risque pour la santé
des autres bidons de date nous ne
faisons pas cela vis-à-vis des
diplomates en iran mais je n'ai jamais
été il n'y a pas eu cela à moscou non
mais c'est ce qu'on fait dans certains
pays certains pays demandent de faire au
moins une prise de température d'autres
demandent un test réalisé pas plus de
quarante-huit heures avant votre arrivée
[Musique]
mais ces pays ne sont pas si c'est le
cas par exemple de la chine avec les
exigences sont très strictes
j'y vais dans une quinzaine de jours ça
ne sera pas facile les rangs et parmi
les pays les plus affectés au moyen
orient
certains experts disent que vous
traversez la troisième vague de la
pandémie en ce moment là 3e louis
beaucoup de hauts fonctionnaires
iraniens sont tombés malades ou sommet
mort du virus
je sais que l'un de vous conseiller ou
amis les plus proches amis un ancien
collègue en est malheureusement mort
avait mis au point vos propres règles ou
habitudes afin de minimiser les risques
car vous êtes fortement exposés vous
communiquez avec beaucoup de gens vous
fait certainement partie d'un groupe à
risque
nous ne pouvons qu essayer de garder la
distance nécessaire mais qui pts non pas
sociale mais physique les écoles de
porter le masque et mais vous porter le
masque n'est ce pas parce que en
arrivant ici vous oui je le porte tout
le temps et c'est valable pour tout le
monde
tous mes collègues portent le masque ce
n'est pas comme si moi j'étais immunisés
et eux devaient le porter vous avez
précédemment évoqué certaines
difficultés pour les rangs au sujet
d'approvisionnement en médicaments et
matériel médical
c'était même le cas avant la pandémie
à quel point ces difficultés sont telles
grave en ce moment cela explique-t-il en
partie que votre pays et autant souffert
de la pandémie et ne fait aucun doute
que les sanctions et les difficultés
économiques que les états unis ont fait
connaître à l'iran ont eu des retombées
significatives et ceux ci de deux
manières
d'abord nous avons dû obliger les gens à
ne pas se rendre au travail
en même temps nous n'étions pas en
mesure de leur fournir des allocations
supplémentaires du raid et donc des
allocations il y en a eu mais il était
impossible d'en verser davantage ce
stade alors les gens ont dû rester chez
eux
mais il fallait bien qu'ils gagnent leur
vie
alors que les caisses de l'état n'était
pas bien pleine béni douala
par conséquent nous avons dû les laisser
gagner leur vie par eux mêmes c'était la
première décision que nous avons dû
prendre une décision très dure mais tout
de même nécessaire à chaque année 2,5 m
ensuite vient la question de l'achat de
médicaments de vaccins chine les etats
unis ont d'abord limiter nos ressources
financières en nous empêchant de vendre
notre pétrole sale et gaulle 1 5 mde et
ils nous empêchent aujourd'hui d'avoir
même accès à notre propre argent
nous avons un peu d'argent en réserve à
l'étranger et les états unis empêche les
pays où se trouve cet argent de nous y
donner accès même pour acheter des
médicaments et cela avec notre propre
argent
les américains disent que leurs
sanctions ne pèse pas sur les aspects
humanitaires mais ce n'est qu'un
mensonge
nous avons essayé de transférer de
l'argent pour le vaccin de l' oms mais
c'était impossible
nous avons même essayé de transférer
l'argent pour un vaccin ordinaire contre
la grippe a mais les restrictions
imposées pour les états unis nous
empêche même de faire des transactions
pour acheter des vaccins donc
fondamentalement c'est à du terrorisme
médical que se livrent les états unis
vous êtes maintenant moscou pour parler
des sujets sensibles puisque vous êtes
venu en personne
je suis également certaines que vous
allez évoqué avec vos collègues russes
la récente décision américaine de
réintroduire l'embargo sur les armements
contre votre pays
après tout le monde à part les états
unis et s'accordent à dire que c'est
donc vous n'avez pas à perdre votre
précieux temps à revenir sur le
caractère illégal de cette tentative
je voudrais que vous nous disiez
honnêtement si vous considérez que cela
peut être efficace même en étant
illégales les etats-unis ont-ils les
moyens d'imposer cette restriction est
de la faire appliquer très certainement
les états unis ont beaucoup de levier
financier
quand il s'agit d'empêcher les pays
d'avoir des rapports entre eux et quand
c'est pour cette raison que les pays
sont de moins en moins dépendant du
dollar
pkd nord azor savent que tant qu'ils en
dépendent pour leurs transactions
internationales des halles ils seront
fondamentalement à la merci des états
unis est subordonnée à leurs caprices
ensuite pour nous c'est une question de
principe
lire on n'achète pas beaucoup d'armes
nous ne sommes pas l'arabie saoudite
avec ses 67 milliards de dollars de
dépenses militaires qui dépasse même
celle de la russie en 2000
mais dan dah nous ne dépensons pas
autant mais dans le rap
nous n'avons pas assez d'argent à
dépenser pour cela la plupart des armes
dont nous avons besoin nous les
produisons nous mêmes nous n'allons pas
sur le marché international en essayant
de nous procurer des armes par ci par là
aucun pays européen ne nous avons dû
d'armes depuis notre révolution on se
fait pas d'illusions mais c'est une
question de principe
il y a eu un accord prévoyant la levée
des sanctions et comme la russie l'a
souligné à juste titre nous n'étions pas
sous embargo
il y avait des restrictions nous devions
avoir la permission du conseil de
sécurité pour acheter et vendre des
armes
cette restriction sera supprimée mi
octobre et c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
important si nous avons besoin de nous
procurer d'acheter des armes à nos amis
il n'y aura plus de restrictions légales
en parlant de vos amis et de l'achat
d'armement on a demandé à votre
homologue russe sergueï lavrov
si les fabricants d'armes russes
allaient continuer à commercer avec
l'iran
il a dit qu'il ne pouvait pas donner de
réponse puisqu'il s'agissait de
décisions d'entreprises privées et que
les américains avaient les moyens
d'influencer le calcul de l'est je
voudrais vous demander à clé réaction
particulière vous attendait de la part
de la russie et de la chine
une condamnation rhétorique serait-elle
suffisante
la russie et la chine sont les premières
à protester contre les mesures
américaines
mais même chez les européens treize
membres sur quinze du conseil de
sécurité ont écrit deux fois une lettre
rejetant cette initiative au président
du conseil
la première fois le 20 août quand les
états unis ont publié ladite
notification et la seconde le 20
septembre quand les américains ont
déclaré que les sanctions de l'onu
seraient prétendument réintroduite c'est
ce qui est important
je pense que c'est un point important
donc une position diplomatique suffit
oui je veux dire il s'agit d'une grande
défaite diplomatique pour les états unis
d'un isolement des états unis d'une
confirmation par la communauté
internationale de la légitimité de la
position iranienne à ce qui est une
réussite importante non seulement pour
l'iran mais aussi pour toute la
communauté internationale et la primauté
du droit
ensuite nous avons des contacts au
niveau militaire avec nos amis ses
contacts vont se poursuivre mais
d'habitude ce genre de chose n'est pas
retransmis en direct à la télévision
je comprends vous avez parlé de la
réaction européenne et je voudrais vous
poser une question sur les européens car
je pense que la russie se trouve
actuellement dans une situation
similaire à celle de léran dans le cadre
de l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
la russie a investi dans le gazoduc le
nord stream est à présent constate que
les européennes promettaient certaines
choses sans procéder à de réels efforts
pour les réaliser peut-on encore
considéré les européens comme des
occidentaux raisonnable car ils n'ont
certainement pas la même rhétorique que
les états unis mais sont ils plus fiable
quand il s'agit d'accords internationaux
quand il faut tenir parole comme vous
l'avez dit nord stream est un très bon
exemple les européens laissent les états
unis les intimider dans le cas de l'iran
bolide
les américains peuvent les intimider
pour ce qui relève de leur survie et
nord stream est très important pour
l'europe
comme vous savez c'est la source
énergétique la plus fiable pour
l'allemagne et même sur ce point les
états unis essaye clairement d'intimider
l'allemagne pour qu'elle renonce à
coopérer avec la russie sur ce projet je
pense qu'il y ait une leçon à tirer de
cette histoire si vous vous laisser
intimider il n'y aura pas de limites à
cette intimidation dans les buts
je pense que les européens doivent s'en
rendre compte
après malheureusement jusqu'à présent il
ya eu beaucoup de belles paroles qu'il
s'agisse de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien ou le nord stream mais pas
beaucoup d'actes de la part des
européens à tes amis
nous avons une longue histoire
nous sommes patients nous savons que la
politique américaine d'intimidation sera
de toute manière rejetée par la
communauté internationale
to be il faut du temps mais nous avons
des milliers d'années d'histoire
nous ne sommes pas comme certains pays
qui n'en ont que 250
j'aimerais bien évoqué cette perspective
historique et partager votre optimisme
mais nous devons aussi faire une petite
pause ça nous revenons dans quelques
instants
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre juste avant la
pause
nous avions commencé à parler de votre
attitude vis-à-vis des etats-unis il
reste un peu plus d'un mois jusqu'à
l'élection présidentielle américaine
je sais que vous dites que l'iran
n'éprouve pas de sympathie particulière
pour l'un ou l'autre des candidats
mais en tant que pays pourvu d'une
grande tradition d'un allié stratégique
vous devez sans doute anticipé plusieurs
scénarios pensez vous que la politique
américaine vis-à-vis de votre pays
dépendra de l'issue du futur scrutin
or psdb évidemment il y aura des
différences en fonction du candidat qui
sera élu président les points de vue
peuvent différer mais je doute que
quelqu'un puisse avoir une vision aussi
extrêmes que celles du président trump
néanmoins il faut prendre en compte la
politique et non la personnalité de
celui qui occupe la maison blanche
je pense que avant même de poser la
question de la future politique
vis-à-vis de l'iran
il faut se demander si le transfert du
pouvoir va se passé calmement aux états
unis au cas où l'ancien vice-président
byden gagnerait l'élection on regarde ce
que nous avons entendu de la part du
président trump la veille
ce sera peut-être un peu plus compliqué
je pense que ses concurrents ne sont pas
très sûr non plus d'accepter sa victoire
s'ils l'emportent donc je pense que
c'est valable des deux côtés on verra
bien du côté de ses concurrents il n'y a
pas beaucoup d'options non plus le
président trump est à la maison blanche
et quand le président actuel dit que les
élections dans son pays vont être truqué
c'est un scénario intéressant qui se
dessine à son opposant jo baden a fait
déjà comprendre qu'ici il était élu il
voudrait que l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien soit réintroduit sous son mandat
votre pays et vous même et avait répondu
en évoquant des conditions préalables
retour de la confiance compensation des
pertes
je suis sûr que vous imaginez que cela
n'arrivera jamais mais je voudrais vous
demander quels que soient vos sentiments
par rapport au comportement des états
unis en réalité les rangs et si
l'intéressé par cet engagement
bien sûr que oui nous avons dit qu'avec
ou sans les états unis si les intérêts
de l'iran sont garanties par l'accord et
nous ne voulons rien qui dépasserait le
cadre de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien
nous voulons que ce qui est à nous ce
qui a été négocié dans le cadre de cet
accord il ne peut pas être renégociés
nous voulons que cela si les autres
parties de l'accord peuvent nous donner
cela nous souhaitons vivre avec nous
leur avons donné particulièrement aux
européens plus d'un an pour mettre en
oeuvre ce qu'ils avaient promis nous ont
fait 11 promesses au niveau des
ministères des affaires étrangères et
ceci à deux reprises mais ils ont été
incapables de ne serait-ce que commencer
à mettre en oeuvre ces onze promesses
pas une seule ensuite nous avons
commencé à diminuer notre engagement
envers l'accord comme c'était inscrit
dans l'accord lui même
donc il s'agit là d'un vrai mécanisme de
résolution des différends et non pas
celui d'un monde parallèle dont parlent
les états unis nous respectons nos
engagements nous ne dépassons pas le
cadre de l'accord il au ps et si les
européens se remettent à l'exécuter s'il
met en oeuvre ce qu'il doit faire ce
sera parfait quel s'épurer l'accord est
effectif
c'est que le conseil de sécurité a
prouvé qu ils les paient deknight states
les etats-unis ont essayé de miner cette
résolution nous étions dans la salle
les etats-unis ont non seulement quitter
cette salle mais ont aussi essayé de
larguer une bombe dans la salle que la
détruire maintenant ils ont mérité de
récupérer un siège dans la salle et ce
n'est pas automatique
je ne suis pas en train d'avancer des
conditions préalables je veux dire vous
ne voulez pas avoir une situation à
l'international où quelqu'un peut
renoncer à un accord quand il le veut et
se réengager comme bon lui semble cela
ne peut pas marcher
alcan bac j'ai regardé votre
intervention au conseil des relations
internationales où vous avez cité ce
merveilleux prover de persan prouve que
nous sommes frères nous demander
d'héritage même si cela paraît très sage
les américains même si en mai trame de
côté ne vivent pas en se fondant sur la
sagesse de perth
ils ont leur propre façon de voir les
choses et en ce moment elle leur
philosophie et de prendre par la force
ce qu'ils considèrent leur nom leur
philosophie est ce qui est à moi
m'appartient ce qui est à toi peut être
négocié tout à fait tout à fait ce n'est
pas une philosophie à laquelle
j'aimerais me soumettre à vous ne voulez
pas vous y se mettre mai
d'après vous quelle est la meilleure
façon d'y faire face car que vous aimiez
cela ou non à vous devez quand même
vivre dans un monde où cette philosophie
laisse une profonde de traces je pense
que l'iran la russie et bien d'autres
pays ne sont pas prêts à laisser cela
devenir la philosophie dominante
nous croyons à l'état de droit à la
primauté des normes internationales nous
croyons que si vous signez retraités
vous devez respecter votre engagement
ce sont des choses auxquelles nous
croyons sinon ce sera la loi de la
jungle
nous pouvons procéder comme ça entre
nous mais qu'en est il des rapports avec
les états unis
nous sommes obligés sinon ça va devenir
une jungle et nous nous sommes pas prêts
à vivre dans une jungle et je ne pense
pas que la russie soit prête à vivre
dans une jungle je ne pense pas que la
chine soit prête
je pense que peu à peu l'europe va
arrêter de se plier au diktat de
washington états membres c'est une façon
à notre sujet car nous n'avons plus
beaucoup de temps
je sais que vous aviez dit que vous
n'étiez pas très impressionnés par le
récent accord entre israël et les
émirats arabes unis avec le bahreïn
l'accord qui établit des liens
diplomatiques complet pourquoi pas
je n'avais je devrais l'être ils ont eu
des rapports stratégiques secrets au
cours des 15 dernières années
l'ambassadeur israélien à washington a
publié sur twitter qu au train de
twitter et sa photo avec youssef al
otaïba l'ambassadeur des émirats arabes
unis en disant je suis ravi de pouvoir
partager avec vous notre vieille amitié
il s'agit d'une amitié de longue date
maintenant ils ont une occasion de faire
une photo à la maison blanche pour aider
trump à se faire réélire en floride
cela peut servir cet objectif mais cela
ne peut pas servir la paix mais monsieur
le ministre les rapports personnels
professionnels sont une chose
de véritables rapports entre états en
sont une autre non il ya eu des rapports
entre les états ces rapports ont été
gardés secrets maintenant sous pression
du gendre de trump ils ont décidé de
rendre cela public afin d'aider trump 1
afin de lui donner une victoire
diplomatique dont ils avaient besoin
étant donné qu'il a un triste cv pour ce
qui est des affaires internationales
pour qu'ils puissent montrer quelque
chose mais il n'ya pas que 30 il sera l
offre en ce moment à ses nouveaux amis
arabes des technologies vital des
possibilités d'investissement c'est
également l'occasion pour les états unis
de vendre plus d'armes à des pays dans
votre région at il vraiment aussi peu
d'importance pour les intérêts de l'iran
n'essayez vous pas de minimiser l'impact
que cet accord peut avoir sur votre
propre situation
non je ne minimise pas l'impact je dis
que c'était un simulacre de justice
vis-à-vis des palestiniens mais ce
n'était pas une réussite diplomatique
majeur ces pays du golfe acquiert 25 %
de la totalité du marché mondial des
armes et ils vont en acheter davantage
compte il fait avec ses 25 %
disons que ça représente 30 40 50%
qu'est ce que ça changera donc ça ne
vous gêne pas du tout belle et douce bad
mais ce qui me gêne c'est que nos
voisins essaie d'acheter une protection
pareil sécurité ils ont toujours essayé
de faire ça donc pocket
n'oubliez pas ils ont toujours essayé
depuis l'époque de saddam hussein et
regardez où cela les a menés ils ont
essayé d'acheter une protection aux
états unis
et les etats-unis les ont en fin de
compte tout simplement abandonné sans
leur fournir aucune protection
maintenant ils essaient d'acheter cette
protection à l'état d'israël qui est
même incapable de se protéger lui-même
contre les palestiniens
je pense qu'ils font une grave erreur
il faut qu'ils tournent leur regard vers
l'intérieur vers leur propre peuple pour
être légitime et à leurs voisins pour
les questions de sécurité
il y a beaucoup de spéculations autour
du prochain pays à suivre l'exemple des
émirats ont dit que cela pourrait être
le moment où le soudan
mais tous les regards sont sans doute
tourner vers l'arabie saoudite et je
pense qu'il y à quelques indicateurs
subtil du fait que l'opinion publique
est en train d'être formés pour
officialiser ce qui existe déjà
officialisé ce qui existe déjà
l'arabie saoudite et israël coopère
depuis des années exactement
mais le fait de le reconnaître pensez
vous que c'est réellement le scénario je
pense que cela n'a pas d'importance je
ne pense pas que cela affecte la
situation de toute façon ils n'ont
jamais aider les palestiniens mais nous
ne parlons pas seulement de la palestine
non je veux dire que tout le problème au
moyen-orient et qu'on piétine les droits
des palestiniens pour y mener tout mais
j'ai il faut considérer tout
développement à travers ce critère est
que ben laden est affecte la lutte des
palestiniens contre l'occupation
permanente toile continue
je ne pense pas que l'arabie saoudite
les émirats arabes unis ou le bahreïn
était de grand soutien à la cause
palestinienne
autrement que d'un point de vue purement
rhétorique je pense donc que cela n'aura
aucun impact réel sur la difficulté dans
notre région
ces difficultés sont liées à
l'expansionnisme à l'agressivité et aux
violations à l'égard du peuple
palestinien
le président trump aime se lançaient des
compliments sur cette nouvelle approche
diplomatique et ses collègues israéliens
comme saoudiens sont prêts à lui donner
ce qu'il veut éloge photos tout en
préservant leurs propres intérêts je ne
pense pas qu'il soit perdant dans cette
situation je sais que les iraniens sont
un peuple fier mais duper son ennemi
peut aussi donner une satisfaction
tu veux un accord avec l'iran vous le
savez je le sais tout le monde le sait
pourquoi ne pas lui donner ce qu'il veut
mais un en posant vos conditions il y à
un principe à vous voulez un accord et
ce n'est pas une histoire de photo
mais nous avons 159 pages d'accord sur
tout ce n'est pas un document de deux
pages qui peut montrer aux caméras à
nanning et je pense que cela sert les
intérêts de tout seul et je ne dis pas
que c'est uniquement dans nos intérêts
ou dans l'intérêt des américains
c'est un accord il ne contient pas tout
ce que nous voulions et il ne contient
pas tous ce que voulaient les états unis
sinon ce serait un acte de capitulation
de la part de l'iran ou des états unis
donc on ne peut pas s'attendre à ce que
les états unis capitule
mais eux ne peuvent pas s'attendre à ce
que l'iran capitule je pense donc que le
président trump a eu ce qu'il lui
fallait
ils veulent appeler le trône t-il
appelons le l'autre homme deal mais
c'est le mieux qu'on puisse faire
je ne vais pas risquer quelque chose que
j'ai négocié je sais à quel point c'est
compliqué mais je ne veux pas laisser
quelque chose qui a été extrêmement dur
à négocier s'évaporer seulement pour
satisfaire l'égo de quelqu'un mais c'est
le ministre avec tout le respect que je
vous dois ma question ne concerne pas
tellement les américains mais les
israéliens et les émirati pensez vous
que c'est une bonne stratégie
pensez vous qu'elle souhaite une
politique intelligente de préserver
les intérêts de votre pays en dedans à
votre partenaire ou adversaires quelque
chose qu'il veut finalement comme vous
le dites
cette histoire de photo ce n'est pas
grand chose pour préserver ce que vous
voulez préserver
pourquoi les rangs ne nécessite pas
quelque chose comme ça je ne vais pas
parler pour israël mais je ne crois
certainement pas que les émirats a eu ce
qu'il voulait ce dont ils ont besoin ce
dont leur peuple a besoin
en ont-ils eu ne serait-ce qu'un peu
beaucoup a été premier oui les promesses
sont des promesses ce ne sont que des
paroles
vous ne pensez pas qu israël et donnera
suite le partage de technologies de
nouvelles opportunités en mettant leurs
partenaires arabes dans leur orbite
je suis sûr que vous croyez que les
israéliens dont ensuite moyon israël a
dit je cite qu'avec notre talon et leur
argent nous pouvons faire beaucoup
d'helvètes il accepter sa volt il y
croire je pense que non d'accord
monsieur le ministre c'est toujours un
plaisir de vous parler merci beaucoup et
bonne chance
merci
[Musique]